I'm in the dirt you understand I'm in
the dirt and I tell a lot of you so many
of you are so interested in getting to
the penthouse and I promise you for the
real ones who love the building who love
the process who love the game
you will realize real quick it doesn't
taste as good up there I love this
dirt and I will stay in this
dirt until the day I die and
then I'll go back into dirt
permanently
[Music]
the
fact that your hands are in the boxes
you're unpacking I come here I don't
know why that surprises me but it kind
of does hearing you even start that way
makes my soul feel good I love being in
the dirt I love being in the trenches I
grew up in a liquor store flea market
sports card shows but yes I like getting
myself into the dirt that's the
acquiesce
that fine your birthday I'm on a real
Mission like as you can see here his
setup isn't for kicks and Giggles we're
really trying to build a Pokemon at
Yu-Gi-Oh what Dragon Ball Z we are very
committed to the collectible Market to
build out this intellectual property in
the same way that I'm committed to the
nft market and the same way that I'm
going to be committed to animation if I
do those three things right for the next
20 years maybe we'll have something
[Music]
nice tossing and turning now it's three
what does it mean for you to have
hundreds of kids discovering the game
this weekend fulfilling at the highest
level and a huge sense of responsibility
because we have a lot of work to do to
continue that momentum we have a real
shot with this game I see it I smell it
I do as an entrepreneur and a builder
and an operator I'm moving around the
ocean like wait there's some blood in
that water I think we've got that blood
in the water I think you'll see a lot of
expansion in the game
going live on Fanatics live with Michael
Rubin the CEO we're gonna open a series
one be friends box we're going for five
six seven thousand so we're about to hit
it hard here I'm really excited about it
the aroma now young lying hard on the
brow trying to feel my quota yeah that's
a little crazy thank you guys so much
I'll show you one of those that's really
great glass and steel that's really rad
it's the way of the future man
[Music]
how about the foreign
just sweating get bashed getting
pulled get stepped on by Corso put it in
the trenches you know I'm always down
here I'm in the dirt you
understand I'm in the dirt and I tell a
lot of you so many of you are so
interested in getting to the penthouse
and I promise you for the real ones who
love the building who love the process
who love the game you will
realize real quick it doesn't taste as
good up there it's not as
natural the dirt is where it's
at I love this dirt and I will
stay in this dirt until the day I
die and then I'll go back in the
dirt permanently fall in love
with the dirt I promise you
everything you want is based on the dirt
the humility the patience the
accountability the understanding
and empathy of others when they on
you this is dirt talk this
dirt top it's the best
down here so what you want to know
blueberry in all forms blueberry
my girlfriend's brother from England
wants to say hi what's up mate I hope
you have the best evening I can't wait
to meet you in person for you I think
you just said to the person I can't wait
to meet you in person yeah right that
keeps people alive dude like if anyone's
going through hard stuff and for you to
say that to him like that's amazing
[Music]
literally cannot take it no worries
happy to do it I can't let you do that
I'm just kidding Air Forces
[Music]
oh my God it was worth the game one more
one more one more I teach
her communication I share your videos
all the time in my class I'm like yeah
we're not gonna watch the textbook video
we're going to watch this how do they
like it they love it some people are
like oh I love garyvee Yeah more and
more now yeah yeah so I appreciate thank
you Brian you inspired me to start my
own charity I'll help donate 42 000
meals between America my guy yeah
I definitely I definitely
contributed
you're doing this here right now and
it's killing it what's the future I want
to integrate the physical world physical
and digital items yeah this project
started as nfts it's always an nft
project that mix right the cop
crew right and then the trading card
National crew those are three different
groups some people fit in all of them
I'm gonna focus on those things and I'm
gonna build out a great team support my
people and try to get this world out
there at scale sure
we're clearing out we'll see you
tomorrow everyone
tonight tonight
[Music]